[Musik]
vor fast einem jahr habe ich einen
eigenen durchgebaut leider konnte ich
damals auf dem kleinen balkon in wir
hatten schlechte den ganzen schmiede
roten stellen wodurch ich erstens nicht
richtig schmieden und zweitens die
klinge nicht richtig herten konnte jetzt
wurde ich aber doch tatsächlich gebeten
passend zum start der serie house of the
dragon also der vorgeschichte zu game of
thrones einfachen ganzes schwer zu
schmieden und zwar das dax ist das in
der serie von print statement algerien
geführt wird einem gerissenen kämpfer
und drachenreiter der mit seiner nichte
raney kategorien um die thronfolge
konkurriert neben könig service schwert
black fire ist dax ist da finde ich das
cool ich werde in der ganzen serie und
da wir seit eingezogen sind und endlich
genug platz haben habe ich mir extra für
den schmiede rufen und dicken amboss
zugelegt mit dem ich jetzt zum ersten
mal schmieden wird einer von euch kam
ein schwert am ende des videos sogar
gewinnen also bleibt dran
dieses video wird unterstützt von dem
streaming-dienst von skype und zwar nur
dort könnt ihr jetzt seit 22 im august
die erste staffel house of the dragon
parallel zum us-start schauen den link
findet ihr in der beschreibung wie
eigentlich alle meine projekte wird auch
das schwert erst mal nicht geplant mit
einem 3d modell und zwar am computer
dafür gehe ich jetzt mal ganz frech auf
google docs ist da und so mehr einzeln
will daraus das schwert wird wie ihr
seht von unterschiedlichen märkten
unterschiedlich beschrieben ich
entscheide mich für dieses design sie
ist in meine cad software und
modellierte jetzt kommt nach
[Musik]
ja natürlich den ganzen tag immer
gebraucht aber weil ich keine ahnung
hatte wie man diese ganzen geschwungenen
formen überall mal aber jetzt weiß ich
viel gelernt und das ergebnis die sich
krass aus genauso legendär wie das dax
ist der walisische stahl aus dem es
geschmiedet wurde und zumindest genauso
schwer zu beschaffen war auch der stall
den ich für meine replica brauche und
der vergleich will was heißen denn das
wissen zur herstellung von vallori zum
stall ging mit dem untergang war julias
ja komplett verloren auf der suche nach
stahl stelle ich fest in einen
baumärkten gibt es nur so dünnes dann im
internet hat man lieferzeiten von bis zu
einem monat wobei der haus auf der
dragon start am 22 august natürlich
nicht auf mich wartet und ich den staat
also schneller braucht und der
metallhändler in der umgebung wollte mir
nur stahl verkaufen wenn ich ihnen
mindestens eine tonne abnehmen darum
habe ich das natürlich gemacht kleiner
spass ich beim baumarkt du kollege wer
ist mein schwert ein richtig scharfes
schwert
autobahn komplett easy pass ist allein
das auch noch
[Musik]
mit dem stahl in der tasche mache ich
mich also an das schmieden der klinge da
ich mich zwar in die schmiede grundlagen
eingelesen abgesehen davon aber keinen
plan vom schmieden habe teste ich meinen
neuen schmiede offen aber erst mal an
einem kleineren stück metall so dass
jetzt schon ganz gut ist auf jeden fall
richtig ja keine ahnung was jetzt machen
wir mal irgendwas
[Musik]
also es geht schon nur oder würde von
100 stück mehr
[Musik]
ja das kann ja was werden ganz schwer zu
machen das war ja jetzt noch gar nicht
mal so gut aber ich habe schon mal ein
gefühl dafür bekommen wie fest ich
zuhören muss und wie man 1000 grad
heißen stein bewegt ohne sich zu
verbrennen also anderen die klingen da
der stahl aus dem baumarkt ja zu dünn
ist schneide ich ihnen erst mal eine
mitte durch und schweißte die beiden
hälften zusammenstellen lässt sich
übrigens mit unserem schweißgerät mega
gut reisen im gegensatz zu aluminium
dass wir letzte woche für das fahrrad
speisen mussten hier entstehen also auch
relativ brauchbare schweißnähte und
damit ein dickes stück das als rohling
für unser schwer zu dient und das muss
jetzt geschmiedet werden bis ich
mindestens die abmaße aber wie in meiner
zeitung am pc noch mal macht man die
meiste arbeit mit so einem
presslufthammer oder mit einer hydraulik
presse was habe ich aber nicht weil es
zu teuer ist deswegen wird jetzt
anstrengen so sieht übrigens meine
schmiede aus am boden und auf der
werkbank liegt eine bis auf 1000 grad
resistenten decke neben dem amboss liegt
eine große steinplatte um heisses
werkzeug ablegen zu können und meine
stand baumaschinen habe ich kurzerhand
als schwert halte umfunktioniert damit
ich den kiloschweren stahl rowling
zusätzlich zum ohnehin schon anstrengen
hämmern nicht auch noch stunden lang
halten muss der schmiede offen stehen
natürlich draußen sonst er wird jetzt
angeworfen
das teil ist jetzt so heiß und blüht
auch dort wird gut
ok
deswegen ist es auch relativ schnell
auskühlt
die
er ist nicht so anstrengend es ist
comeback an das projekt 100 oder gar
nichts normal waren angenehm
geräte schon
aber
jetzt so richtig viel
wenn der staat aus dem ofen kommt muss
es extrem schnell gehen denn das
zeitfenster in dem sich der stall
effektiv verformen lässt ist bei uns
gerade mal zwei minuten kaum ist sie auf
ca unter 700 grad abgekühlt muss man
wieder fünf bis zehn minuten warten bis
man weiter spielen kann
[Musik]
34 30 haben diagnose als die hälfte
geschafft hast aber geht also es sei
jetzt jedoch kaum mehr kaputt aber ich
habe schon das gefühl dass die dinger
vorher schon ordentlich zusammen gehen
und wenn man erstmal den stall rathaus
vorbei
[Musik]
der 5 kilogramm vorschlaghammer verformt
den stahl mit purer gewalt das kostet so
enorm viel energie dass wir nicht einmal
die zwei minuten durchhalten die der
stahl verformbar ist und uns sobald der
erste ausgepowert ist direkt abwechseln
[Musik]
das ding jetzt gerade noch gerade
gebogen megageil es ist wirklich krass
also sieht eigentlich richtig weg aus in
euren augen wahrscheinlich aber in
meinen augen sieht das einmal richtig
wunderschön aus und mit ein bisschen
fantasie ist es auch einfach schon
schwer tat sich das die meiste arbeit an
der klinge jetzt schon gemacht ist es
war wirklich mega will die wand zu zweit
und es hat trotzdem komplett kreis wir
konnten gerade mittagspause kaum egal
behalten aber es hat richtig gut
geklappt jetzt wird einmal die form vom
schwert ausgedruckt und drauf geklebt
und wir zugestimmt und geschliffen jetzt
gar
[Musik]
das ding hier ist richtig richtig cool
allerdings nur so dreckig jetzt wird
geschliffen und damit richtig schön und
zuerst mal scharf sein erstmal flachen
das teil auch mal ein schwert aus
[Musik]
ich bin ich werd form jetzt wie gesagt
eher fertig jetzt viel aber jetzt noch
quasi diese wunderschöne verzierungen an
der klinge mit seiner konstruktion habe
ich ja so eine richtig schöne mulde
reingehe designt ziehen wir jetzt meine
linie von genau der mitte hier hinten
bist du genau der mitte hier vorne
ich glaub das schlauste jetzt erstmal
group mit der flex weg zum leben
[Musik]
aha so fürs erste selbstständig etwas
schwert ist das bin ich mega geil so
kann das wird allerdings nicht bleiben
weil wenn ich jetzt irgendwie außer
dagegen kommen ist da direkten mega
delle drin deswegen musste jetzt noch
gehärtet werden so wie es ist dafür habe
ich mir bereits die schublade bereit
gestellt und mit dem gartenschlauch mit
wasser gefüllt und jetzt geht das
schwert nochmal ein ofen bis ungefähr so
800 grad und damit ins kalte wasser
geworfen
[Musik]
wenn es hart auf hart käme könnte man
damit jetzt in der schlacht schon ein
bisschen was ausrichten und hart auf
hart kommt auf jeden fall auch in der
ersten staffel von house of the dragon
für das wäre dieses schwert nachbauen
denn dort kommt das schwert also dax ist
direkt in der ersten folge schon zweimal
zum einsatz unter anderem bei einem
großen turnier schaut euch das also
unbedingt an die seele aus dem game of
thrones universum gibt seitdem 2017/18
stream und zwar nur bei den link dazu
und zu allem anderen was one film und
serien zu bieten hat findet ihr in der
video bis heute zurück zu einem schwert
bau damit man beim zustechen mit seinem
schwert nicht schmerzhaft mit der hand
über die klinge rutscht haben wir eine
so genannte pariert stange da nicht aber
noch nicht genau weiß wie ich die
umsetzen soll schmeiß ich die datei erst
mal in 3d drucker wir müssen jetzt das
teilnehmen was die pariert stark das ist
einmal ein 3d foto entstanden problem
das aus plastik thalmässing jetzt kann
was er drauf passt perfekt als hätte ich
es genauso designt jetzt müsse das
irgend ausschneiden ich weiß noch nicht
genau wie weil ich nicht mit messing
gearbeitet haben wir zwei
drei methoden also ein cuttermesser
überhaupt nicht machte sturm war aber
hey fleck jetzt
geht macht
also das geht schon mal wenn du damit
alles auch schon alles an bis zum tod
ich habe eine andere idee ich hab
nämlich auch noch dünneres messing das
ist halb so dick
und man kann sind hoffentlich besser
schneiden konstruieren
[Musik]
ich glaube dass ich dafür ja problemlos
das könne nicht funktionieren gleich
eine sache auf der spur die wirklich gut
funktioniert könnte ich hab das jetzt
schon mal hier so umgebogen und jetzt
muss ich das zeug nur noch abschleifen
meiner seite und das problem
[Musik]
das hat jetzt echt erstaunlich gut
geklappt ich glaube dass die beiden
hälften zusammen genauso und dann wird
der rest gemacht das wird richtig nein
[Musik]
es ist fertig es war ein mega welcher
form wir haben es irgendwie hingekriegt
das geiste ist
es fühlt sich einfach absolut metalle
schon wehrt sich anderen hört sich auch
so an noch wertvoller wird es aussehen
wenn wir dann edelsteinen draufmachen im
mittelalter hatte man das noch nicht
heute aber schon zwei komponenten kleber
kommen jetzt zwei flüssigkeiten beide
für sich kleben die überhaupt nicht aber
wenn man die mischt wird das teil
richtig aggressiv so da kommen jetzt mal
was drauf er sehe ich da wieder drauf
gesetzt die andere seite
gold und rot sehr sehr edel nehmen wir
die pariert stange schieben dass teile
einmal drauf also wenn das nicht schon
mal ein schwert ist es ist komplett geil
allerdings der griff natürlich auch
richtig schlecht kann es überhaupt nicht
halten ist komplett überall hin zum
kommerz erklärt so wir machen jetzt
kürzungspläne trifft nun einmal
metallstab hier in den schraubstock
damit der gewinner schneider ja einmal
ins bild eisen eingespannt
okay das macht überhaupt keinen spaß ich
mache jetzt mal was illegales
doch wird schon schief geht
[Musik]
auch jetzt wird noch weder
das ist gerade passiert dafür aber
irgendwie wanderfalke irgendwas gerissen
gut ich habe gesagt es wird bilder aber
ich glaube dass ich jetzt mal was noch
weiter zumindest für leute die das
beruflich machen
so perfekt
[Musik]
das dax ist dann muss natürlich auch gut
in der hand legen dafür hat das original
was aussieht wie ein leder griff das
machen jetzt auch hier für einmal ein
stück leder das muss ich das geld zu
schneiden und
fertig wenn sie die wahrheit so etwas
klappt sehr gut und jetzt muss noch die
naht hier gelingen
und jetzt ungeschlagen
hat viel besser geklappt als ich dafür
damit liegt auf jeden fall jetzt schon
richtig guten hand fühlt sich auch sehr
sehr gut an das dax- esther hat aber
jetzt hier quasi noch so eine leder
korten drumrum aufgewickelt und das
machen wir jetzt punkte fix genau und
jetzt wird stück für stück geklebt
[Musik]
jetzt noch mal richtig gut grip also es
ging auch nicht rutscht und sieht super
aus
[Musik]
kommen wir zum ein stück also zudem
legen das ganz am ende vom schwert und
an den grid angeschraubt wird um alles
zusammenzuhalten ihr habt ja für einmal
diesen messing rund staat wohl da kann
er ein ich hole die taucherbrille spaß
und ich kann frau wurde und fahren hier
fröhlich anzusehen
das mittelstück vom entwickler jetzt
kann man zu den coolen flammen denken
und da vielleicht überlegt neben
versionen blech und das wird jetzt rund
gemacht also so rund dass es den messing
zylinder perfekt umschließt gut ich
werde hart löten was ich auch noch nie
gemacht habe das ist eine mischung
zwischen löten und schweißen ganz wird
gesagt vorfeld extra die übertriebenen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen auch
aber das mit dem harten hat irgendwie
nicht so richtig geklappt warum könnt
ihr gerne in die kommentare schreiben
aber so ging es auf jeden fall nicht
also ziemlich einfach und nehme normales
lützen ich weiß nicht so recht ob das
hart löwen war am ende einfach glaube
ich normalen lötzinn genommen aber es
hält bereich mit der am bandschleifer
runde ich das messing teil einmal ab
aber für die feinarbeit muss ich noch
mal selbst hand anlegen das ganze
schleifen geht auf dauer recht auf die
arme aber dann habe ich urplötzlich den
dreh raus ist hätte ich mein leben lang
nichts anderes gemacht jetzt denkt ihr
dass sie dann auch überhaupt nicht aus
wie waldsachs ist stimmt das kommt jetzt
nachdem ich die flammen group abgeflext
und verbogen habe teile ich sie noch mal
leicht ab und nachdem pascal das teil
noch mal drei stunden politik sieht es
dann so aus absolut schön ein sehr
gelungenes stück und ich werde eine
lodernde flamme die jetzt hinten drauf
kommt und über das gewinner aber dort
gedreht wird bis das fest eingespannt
dass es edel das ist sehr sehr edel und
es ist fertig das pferd ist damit
offiziell komplett fertig das unten sind
so krasse aus absolut geil ich würde
sagen jetzt getestet sparen dafür kommen
dass wer direkt zum einsatz zum entasten
funktioniert gar kein problem hier
richtig geil muss man aufpassen weil ich
habe schon in der mache den finger genau
so eine aktion
soll schon einmal hier ein gutes stück
fallobst
ich hoffe ich treffe was
[Musik]
man aber ich trage dich nicht
geil
[Musik]
apple war kein problem jetzt geht ans
holz
[Musik]
wie anfangs bereits erwähnt könnt ihr
diese schwer zu gewinnen sofern ihr über
18 sein zum start von house of the
dragon verlosen wir nehmen dich zusammen
mit wow und erschwert das ist alles was
ihr dafür machen wir das ist in die
kommentare zu schreiben was ihr denkt
wie viel dieses gute stück hier wiesen
man hinten ist wiegt der ist oder das
gewicht auf zwei nachkommastellen
genauer schätzt oder eben der der nach
einer woche am nächsten dran ist bekommt
das schwer alle teilnahmebedingungen
findet ihr noch mal eine video
beschreibung genau so wie in dem video
beschreibung den link zur serie house of
the dragon findet und allem anderen was
war so zu bieten hat an filmen und
serien was geschah vor game auch dort
und ich bin damals raus